hello Jean who are you the better
question is who are you something's
happening to me you would have this
control bad things but it feels good you
shutting down Hollywood Boulevard
tonight this is Big Mac I saw you come
in it looked like you were so excited to
see everyone you had a whole bunch week
folks with you who to bring tonight did
you bring the whole family I brought so
my family can't be here but I brought my
husband and my friend Nadia and their
family
oh wait that's the original Jean Grae
famke janssen kids I can she she's not
Jean anymore listen that's a Marvel
moment that's a Marvel moment I had to
have that you never met her before I've
met her once before and I don't think
she recognized me because I had gone
home and I met her she was like hello
and I was like I'm Sophie and she was
like okay and I love that this is date
night what is it like to have I mean you
said you brought your husband to have
him sitting beside you when you're
showing the world this movie it's great
it's wonderful it's it's nerve-wracking
but it's amazing it's a bit of comfort
and otherwise nerve-racking day
that's right
[Music]